[Music]
all right rachel we like to have some
fun and that means reacting to videos on
the internet that james sends us
and the latest one is a fun one because
it's gary vaynerchuk who i find
personally very entertaining yes
generally insightful
he's got a potty mouth so you know
luckily this clip is
this clip is safe it's radio friendly
guys don't the fcc is not coming after
us
but he's talking about investing now
he's a social media expert entrepreneur
author speaker but he's big into the
trendy investments of the day including
nfts and crypto and all that very cool
so we we yes he's very cool we disagree
on a lot of things in that in the
financial space but he had something
interesting to say because he does have
his finger on the pulse of the trends
that are happening out there among the
youth of america so let's see what gary
has to say the youth
if you go look at tiktok accounts of 15
16 17 year olds you have 16 year olds
that have in their bio investor and i'm
like this is profound what i'm seeing is
a bigger convo the rise of people saying
i'm an investor too and then the rise of
what they want to invest in so now
you've got 15 to 30 year olds that think
about investing but they don't want to
buy a one family bedroom and make
recurring revenue on rent they want to
buy a pair of nikes that are going to go
up 2x they want to buy john marant
rookie cards they want the nft to put in
their social media profile and they want
it to go up that's very different than
buying 75 shares of turner because
investing is now more pop culture and
fashion everyone now sees it as a viable
cultural thing you do and they just are
going to do it in new stuff so
alternative investments that is a big
deal and it hasn't begun
interesting and it hasn't begun
he's teasing it rachel this is the
future we're living in
it's no longer just pokemon cards i feel
like people always kind of did that kind
of stuff though i mean not like nfts
obviously but i feel like but now with
social media it's a different ball game
because it's like a flex now yeah to
have this facade of like i'm an investor
like that's who i am
i knew a guy uh one of my cousin's
friends and he would come to nashville
drive to nashville because we have a
nike outlet in cool springs outside of
nashville
and he would come and like rack up and
he had an online store and he would sell
shoes that was like his thing and he'd
drive around but he also had like a
full-time job but it was like the sad
thing about his side hustle but i feel
like it paid pretty well so i'm like
i mean great that's awesome well these
people are passionate about a certain
little you know match and whether it's
shoes or nfts and they kind of make it a
side hustle and they might make a little
money and sometimes it turns into a
full-time gig for some people yeah and
it's not a bad thing but it can't be
your only thing like when you're still
not in my opinion
investing in the things that have a long
track record that are predictable that
you know what's going to happen
uh aka the market or 401ks raw fire it's
like like especially with retirement
like that stuff for me is still a
no-brainer and then once you've done
that
and you want to go
dabble in something with some money
knowing it's kind of a gamble um i mean
that's your prerogative if that's what
you want to do but
but it's fascinating that how it's
trendy though which i kind of appreciate
i'm like i'm so glad money has become
like being cool to talk about now yes
which is fun
but there is a piece of this where
anything you know i've i've said if you
follow the trends you will fall for the
traps and that is my worry with what's
happening is that these folks are
falling into nfts and they spend two
thousand dollars on an nft and they go
to try to resell it and nobody wants it
for ten dollars and that's what we're
seeing which is happening yes that whole
industry it's a reality that i was
absolutely tanked absolutely tanked so
that's it's all a gamble like when
you're doing something new and what's on
trend it's a gamble you have to know
that so don't
so we're not mad at that stuff just to
be clear we're not like no those get off
my lawn it's just more of a
if you're following our baby steps
you're investing 15 of your income into
retirement meaning your 401ks your iras
mutual funds
before we start going all right we're
going to have some play money we're
going to invest in some shoes some
crypto we're not mad at that but don't
make that your investing plan overall
that is not a good strategy because
honestly the crypto and the nft
the way it's gone
is not good not good at all not good so
i i know someone rachel purse very
personally who put their entire life
savings stop it into dogecoin no no
we're talking over 400 thousand dollars
george i'm right here james is right
there i wish i could say it was james
that'd make me it wouldn't make me happy
i don't want anything i don't wish that
for james james but out of all the smart
people in my life that's not james
that 400 something thousand turned into
80 000.
and now they are in debt to fidelity for
hundreds of thousands of dollars for
margin calls and it's greed is what it
comes down to yeah it's get rich quick
and it's what we rally against every day
here at ramsey solutions for 30 years
dave has been rallying against this
culture of get rich quick and the trends
change it used to be zero down real
estate and gold and buy this course and
now it's sneakers who knew who knew
so it's part of what we do at our
building wealth event rachel which we
didn't mean this is not a pitch but it's
what we do at this building wealth event
we've been taking around the country
we've got four or five of these events
this fall and dave does a great talk
about what he's seen in 30 years when it
comes to investing and get rich quick
and then we lay out the plan to get rich
the right way and it's usually a lot
slower it's lower and not as exciting
can we say that george i feel like we
would have a very exciting message we
were like had a webinar or a seminar we
had all the youth in america there and
we were like your 401k guys is going to
get you they're all going to stare at us
and leave and go buy nfts we're like go
go fund your 401k it's so great and in
20 years you'll be able to like this is
awesome this nft these sneakers all of
it like this is the future this is
what's happening and it might right like
i'm sure i'm at the humble opinion
things may change i'm not mad at that i
need at least a long track record before
i go and put my own money in it yes
and so that that is the bigger issue and
these 16 17 year old 18 year olds
they're living with mom and dad probably
and some of them are amazing
entrepreneurs and i'm like these are the
kids we're all gonna be working for one
day these are really sharp amazing kids
and what i want for them is to have a
long-term success not short-term success
and flail out and they're also trying to
pay off their student loan debt because
they wandered into that and they also
have credit card debt in a car loan
because they're flexing for the gram and
so this is where it becomes you're doing
too many things at once and you're never
going to build wealth that way that
lasts yep so there's my soapbox for the
day